الهدنه في السودان تدخل حيزه تنفيذ لاربعه
وعشرين ساعه واشنطن تؤكد مواصلتها الضغط
على الجيش والدعم لوقف الحرب
بعد اتهامه في قضيه حيازه وثائق سريه موقع
اكسيوس يؤكد ان الاتهام ولدانه لا يمنعان
ترامب من الترشح للرئاسه الامريكيه 2024
كاميرا العربيه توثق حجم كارثه سيد نوفا
المدمر من الجانب الروسي وترصد العالقين
وتسلط الضوء على جهود الانقاذ
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره اخباريه من العربيه دخلت الهدنه في
السودان قبل لحظات حيز التنفيذ بين الجيش
والدعم السريع ولمده 24 ساعه فقط بعد ان
اعلنت الخارجيه السعوديه عان اتفاقا بين
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع لوقف اطلاق
النار كانت السعوديه والولايات المتحده
اكدت في بيان المشترك انه في حال عدم
التزام طرفي الصراع في السودان بالهدنه
فسيكونان مضطرين لتاجيل المحادثات في جده
[موسيقى]
ومن الخرطوم معنا الصحفي والاعلامي ابو
بكر السماني ابو بكر اهلا بك صباح الخير
كيف يبدو الوضع في الخرطوم والسودان مع
دخول الهدنه حيزه التنفيذ
صباح الخير لك والمتابعين قناه العربيه
ونتمنى ان تكون ايضا هدنه خير لكل الكعبه
السوداني دخلنا بالفعل في هذا التوقيت
الذي يشهد اللحظات والدقائق الاولى لهذه
الخدمه ما بين القوات الشعب المسلحه وقوات
الدعم السريع غير انه السودانيون عاشوا
ليله هادئه منذ منتصف ليله امس وحتى عند
الخامسه وسبعه وثلاثين دقيقه الى 5:39
دقيقه في هذا التوقيت استمعنا الى ما يشبه
اطلاق النار واطلاق النار المتبادل بعدها
وعند الخامسه وخمسه وخمسين دقيقه ايضا
استمعنا لطلق ناري واحد يبدو انه من
مدفعيه ثقيله من بعدها والى هذه اللحظه لم
نشهد الاصوات الاخرى حسب الافادات التي
جاءتنا ان هذا هذه الاطلاق للناس سمع في
تلك التوقيتات التي ذكرتها هذا الاطلاق
الانذار وهذه الجديده انقسم فيها تقريبا
السودانيون ما بين مؤيد ومعارض مؤيد يرون
انها فيها بارقه من الامل وانها جاءت وسط
ضغوط دوليه كبيره جدا فلذلك هم بالتالي
يتوقعون نجاح هذه الحنه المعارضون او
الذين لا يتفقون مع نجاحات الهدنه يقولون
لماذا لا تكون هذه الهدنه شبيهه
للاخريات من الهدن اذا ما بين هذا وذاك
يدخل السودان والسودانيون هدنه من حيث
القراءه نعتبرها مهمه جدا بعد وسط الضغوط
دوليه كبيره جدا خاصه ان انتوني بلينكن
عندما زار جده في زيارته الاخيره ناقشها
على هامش هذه الزياره واعرب عن عمله نعم
بالنسبه للوضع الميداني الى اي مدى يعول
على هذه الهدنه هذه المره لادخال
المساعدات الانسانيه واستعاده الخدمات
الاساسيه بالنسبه للسودانيين
نعم طبعا هذه الهدنه اصلا كان لها سببان
اساسيان وهما فتح الممرات الامنه وايضا
السبب الاخر هو وقف الاقتتال وانا اعتبرها
طبعا هما وجهان لعمله واحده والاساس
وقت اطلاق النار لانه بدون الوقت اطلاق
النار لا يمكن ان تكون هناك امنه اذا تحقق
هذا الهدف فبالتالي يمكن ان نسمع عن ممرات
وعند دخول لهذه الممرات والكوادر الطبيه
وان يستفيد السودان والسودانيون من هذه
الهدنه وبالتالي هي يمكن ايضا ان تؤطر
وتفتح الابواب
لمراحل اخرى ومسارات جديده سياسيه يمكن ان
تؤدي الى مائده الطبخ على العكس تماما اذا
شهدت اي خروقات او شهدنا اي خروقات لهذه
الغده هذا سوف ينعكس سلبا على الطرفين
وايضا سوف ينعكس سلبا على المجتمع
السوداني الذي
على ما يدور الان
الخروقات هل هناك اي اليه واضحه اليوم في
السودان لمراقبه الهدنه وتنفيدها
نعم هذه الاليه طبعا هي كانت واضحه من
خلال ما اعلن عنه بان الاليه سوف يضاف
اليها بند جديد وهي المراقبه عن طريق
المسيرات طبعا فيما مضى كان المراقبه تكون
عن طريق المراسلين على الارض والاقمار
الاصطناعيه وايضا المشاهدات وفيديوهات
المجتمع المحلي الان هنالك اضافه جديده
وهي هذه المسيرات الى الان طبعا لم نشهدها
ولم نسمع عن وجودها لكن نترقب طبعا
وبالتاكيد عندما يقول
المسيره الميثران عفوا بهذا فانه لابد ان
يكون هناك ملاحظه ومتابعه فبالتالي هم
يضيفان مبدا جديدا وربما يحاولان ان
يثبتان لطرفي النزاع ان هذه
الهدنه سوف تكون مراقبه ومراقبه بشكل كبير
جدا واذا هما يتوقعان ان يلتزم الالتزام
الكافي الذي وقعه ووقع عليه في جده
بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه نعمل كثيرا
طبعا ان تنجح هذه الفتنه لانه كما قلت هي
مهمه جدا لكل الطرفين وايضا هي مهمه للشعب
السوداني الذي يترقبها ويتوقع او على
الاقل نصف الناس يعني تتوقع ان تنجح هذه
الهدنه لاهميتها في ان تصل المساعدات
الانسانيه ان يصلوا اهلهم وذويهم يتفقدوا
احوالهم هناك من لم يصل داره ومحله في
التجاري او الوظيفي الى هذه اللحظه منذ
الخامس عشر من ابريل الماضي حين اندلعت
الحرب في السودان ولا زالت روحها الى الان
في مثلث العاصمه القوميه
المجتمع الحادي كما قلت يتابع ويتابع
بصوره كبيره جدا
ويؤكد انه حريص كل الحر على نجاح هذه
الهدنه السؤال هنا ايضا اذا لم تنجح هذه
الخدمه في اي هد نه اخرى يمكن ان تنجح
تكون مسارات الحل اصبحت ضيقه جدا وبالتالي
المصداقيه تكون قلت من كلا الطرفين لعدم
دخلت الهدنه بين الجيش والدعم السريع حيز
التنفيذ لمده 24 ساعه شكرا جزيلا للخرطوم
الصحفي والاعلامي ابو بكر السماني
قال مكتب الشؤون الافريقيه بوزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه عند الولايات المتحده
تواصل الضغط على القوات المسلحه وقوات
الدعم السريعه لوقف الاعمال العدائيه
وتسهيل وصول المساعدات الانسانيه واستعاده
الخدمات الاساسيه اوضح المكتب في تغريده
على تويتر انهم يراقبون الاطراف المتحاربه
في السودان باستخدام الاقمار الصناعيه
وادوات اخرى
قتل 13 شخصا واصيب عشرون اخرون خلال
الشبكات عرقيه في مخيم لحمايه المدنيين
تابع للبعثه الاماميه في جنوب السودان
بحسب ما اعلنت وكاله الامم المتحده لتنسيق
الشؤون الانسانيه ذكرت الوكاله الاماميه
في بيان ان انعدام الامن هذا يعوق الانشطه
الانسانيه مشيره الى تعليق عمليات نقل
الفارين من الصراع في السودان من النقاط
الحدوديه نحو مخيم مال كال شمال العاصمه
جوبا
[موسيقى]
افاد موقع عكس الامريكي بان اتهام الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامبو حتى ادانتي
ايضا لا تمنعانه من الترشح للرئاسه
الامريكيه السند الموقع لرئي خبير دستوري
امريكي يشغل منصب استاذ مساعد بالجامعه
الامريكيه كريس اديلسن الذي قال ان لوائح
الاتهام وحتى الادانات المحتمله لن تحرم
ترامب قانونا من الترشح لرياسه عام 2024
حيث ان الدستور الامريكيه يتطلب ثلاثه
شروط في مرشح الرئه وهي ان يكون مواطنا
امريكيا وان لا يقل عمره عن 35 عاما وان
يكون عاش في الولايات المتحده 14 عاما على
الاقل
وقد ابدل الارشيف الوطني الامريكي في بيان
النادي الرفضه لما اسماها بمزاعم الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب وفريق دفعه بشان
احقيه الاحتفاظ بوثائق السريه نفل ارشيف
الوطني في بيان هذا الادعاء الى انه لا
توجد سوابق تاريخيه او ممارسات او نص في
القانون يعطي للرؤساء الحق في اخذ سجلات
رسميه معهم عندما يغادرون مناصبهم لفرزها
خلال فتره عامين
في المقابل طلب الجمهوريون في رساله
الامريكي بوفاه اجتماع مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي مع وزاره العدل اف بي اي قبل
بدء تفتيش منزل ترامب الرساله تطالب بجميع
المستندات التي تتضمن اجتماعات بين مكتب
التحقيقات الفيدرالي ووزاره العدل او
العدل قبل تنفيذ امر تفتيش ووفق موقع فضلا
عن الوثائق المتعلقه بامر البحث
والاتصالات بين وكلاء مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي في واشنطن والخدمه السريه
الامريكيه حدد سيناتور جيم جوردن يوم
السادس عشر من الشهر الجاري موعدا نهائيا
لتسليم الوثائق
وقد رد الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب على
المدعي العامله الامريكي الخاص جاكس مثل
الذي اصدر لائحه الاتهام بحقه بالقول انه
بموجب بقانون السجلات الرئاسيه يسمح له
بفعل كل هذا لكنه لم يوضح ما المقصود
بعباره كل هذا واكدت سي ان ان انه لا يوجد
في قانون السجلات الرئاسيه ما يسمح للترمب
بتبرير ما قام به من الاحتفاظ بسجلات
ووثائق رسميه
على الجانب الاخر حتى كبار الديمقراطيين
في الكونغرس الامريكيه على المضي قدما في
قضيه اتهام رئيس السابق دونالد ترامب حتى
الزعيمان الديمقراطيان
في بيان مشترك حثى على السماح لقضيه ترامب
بالمضي قدما بشكل سلمي في المحكمه بعد ان
وجهت ليلى لائحه الاتهام الشراي الى انه
لا احد فوق القانون بمن في ذلك دونالد
ترامب اعتبر الزعيمان الديمقراطيه ان
لائحه الاتهام يجب ان تتم الان من خلال
العمليه القانونيه بدون اي تدخل سياسي او
ايديولوجي خارجي
نشر المحقق الخاص الامريكي جاكس ميث النص
الكامل للاتهامات الموجهه للرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب واعتبر ان خلق
القوانين يعرض امن البلاد
تتعلق بجنح خلق قوانين الامن القومي
والتعاون مع اخرين في عرقله العداله
وتشمل الاتهامات الموجهه الى ترامب
الاحتفاظ بوثائق مصنفه سريه وعاليه
الحساسيه بالاضافه الى نقلها واخفائها عن
رجال القانون وكشف مضمونها لاشخاص غير
مرخص لهم بذلك كما تشمل التهم عرقله عمل
رجال القانون والادلاء بتصريحات كاذبه
والتعاون مع الاخرين لعرقله عمل رجال
القانون والادلاء بتصريحات كاذبه وقد حصل
المحققون على تسجيلات من صحفيين تثبت ان
ترامب عرض عليهم الوثائق السريه كما حصل
المحققون على نصوص رسائل هاتفيه تبادلها
ترامب مع عاملين في مارلاجو يتحدث فيها عن
نقل الوثائق او اخفائها
اعتبر ترامب منذ الاعلان عن توجيه التهم
له انه بريء
في المقابل اعتبر محامي ترامب قبل ان
يستقيل ان لا اساس لهذه الاتهامات نعلم ان
المحقق الخاص مصر على اعتبار الامر انه
جريمه ولا اعتقد ان هناك اي اساسا وفقا
لقانون السلطات الرئيسيه ومنذ الاعلان عن
الاتهامات وقفت زعامات الحزب الجمهوري الى
جانب ترامب واعتبرت ان اداره الرئيس
الحالي جوزيف بايدن تستغل وزاره العدل ضد
ترشيحه ترامب الجمهوري
نلتقي اليوم في نيو هامشون وهو يوم حزين
ياتي بعدما واجه رئيس سابق للولايات
المتحده اتهامات غير مسبوقه من قبل وزاره
عدل يديرها الرئيس الحالي الرئيس الامريكي
نفى من جهته الاتصال بوزاره العدل
وتوجيهها الاتهام الى
لن اتحدث اليهم ابدا ولن افعل ذلك
ستتم اجراءات ما قبل المحاكمه في فلوريا
الامريكيه حيث يقيم الرئيس السابق ويعتبر
الخبراء القانون انها قضيه على قدر عال من
الجديه والخطوره
انها قضيه جديه بدون شك ومحاكمه خطيره يجب
النظر اليها بصرف النظر عن الاطار السياسي
ستاخذ هذه القضيه الكثير من وقت
الامريكيين خلال الاسابيع والاشهور
المقبله وتتزامن مع الانتخابات الرئاسيه
حيث يتقدم ترامب على منافسيه الجمهوريين
واحيانا على الرئيس الحالي والمرشح
الديمقراطيم العربيه
وفيها بعد الفاصل
يعلن انه سينشر الاسلحه النوويه تكتيكيه
في بيلاروسيا قبيل اجتماع الناتو الشهر
القادم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال
الرئيسيه في بيلاروسيا بعد اكتمال جاهزيه
المرافق الخاصه في السابع والثامن من
يوليو لتكون هذه هي المره الاولى التي
تنشر فيها موسكو تلك الرؤوس خارج روسيا
مدن هي الاتحاد السوفيتي
قبيل قمه النيتو روسيا تنشر اسلحه نوويه
تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا واوكرانيا تكثف
هجماتها
الاتفاق المبرم بين موسكو وميسك لنشر
اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه روسيه في بيلاروسيا
خلال شهر يجري على قدم وساق بعد اكتمال
جاهزيه المرافق الخاصه بها والرئيس الروسي
يؤكد ان كل شيء يمضي حسب الخطه هذا
الانتشار من المقرر ان يبدا قبيل قمه حلف
شمال الاطلسي التي تنطلق في الحادي عشر من
يوليو في ليتوانيا والتي ستبحث ترشيح
اوكرانيا للانضمام الى الحلف الرئيس
الروسي اتهم الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
الغربيين بمد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه كجزء من
حرب بالوكاله موسعه تهدف الى اخضاع روسيا
الحرب في اوكرانيا معركه بقائم بالنسبه
لروسيا امام توسع النيتو الذي لا ينتهي
واحذر الغرب من ان بلادي لن تتراجع وكان
الاتحاد الاوروبي قد اعرب عن ادانته
للاتفاق المبرم بين روسيا وبيلاروسيا
واعتبر ان من شانه ان يؤدي الى مزيد من
التصعيد محذرا من انه سيقابل برد فعل قوي
ومنسق
الذي اكد ان اوكرانيا اطلقت هجومها المضاد
اشار الى انه تم ردع جهود كياف حتى الان
لكنه اعترف بان القوات الاوكرانيه
مازالت تتمتع بقدرات هجوميه
من جهته اشاهد الرئيس الاوكراني فولو
دوميرسي في خطابه الليلي ببطوله جيشه من
دون الاشاره الى هجوم مضاد او الى عمليه
عسكريه محدده
نركز اهتمامنا على كل الاماكن التي تتطلب
تحركاتنا وحيث يمكننا هزيمه العدو
ان قواتها مستعده لشن هجوم مضاد لاستعاده
اراضي في الشرق والجنوب لكنها اوضحت انه
لن يكون هناك اعلان رسمي لتوقيت انطلاقه
كاميرا العربيه وثقت حجم الكارثه من الطرف
الروسي لسد نوفا كخوف كان مدمر في مقاطعه
خرسون حيث العالقين في بلدات وقرى في
مدينه نوفاكاخوفكا وضواحيها سلطت الضوء
على جهود انقاذ الناجين من القرى الغارقه
رغم القصف المستمر بين طرفين
ينقل الصوره من منطقه فيضان
من هذه النقطه التي تفصلنا عن قلب مدينه
او بلده
خمسه كيلومترات تفصلنا عن قلب المدينه كما
ان المدينه التي تليها هي كورسكنا خلفي
هنا وسط المدينه وهذا هو الشارع الرئيسي
حيث الاناره ونرى اليافطات والاشارات
اشارات المرور ولا بد من الاشاره الى ان
العالقين او الناجين او من تم اجلائهم
واعدادهم تصل الى خمسه الاف مواطن قد
اصطحبوا امتعتهم
ووثائقهم معهم كما ان اكثر من 60 او 70
مصاب نقلوا الى المشافي رغم حجم الكارثه
الكبير الذي خلفه فيضان نهر دنيبرو بعد
قصف وتدمير سد نوفيكا خوفكا اكثر من عشرين
الف بيت داخل هذه المنطقه غمرتها المياه
بالكامل الحديث عن 300 عالق حتى الان
مفقودون في هذه المنطقه التي غمرتها
المياه بالكامل ايضا الحديث عن قريه اخرى
مجاوره لهذه القريه
الحديث عن مصرع سبعه اشخاص هناك لجان خاصه
من المتطوعين يعملون باستمرار منذ ساعات
الصباح الباكره كما نرى خلفي في الصوره
هناك فان العمليات العسكريه ما زالت
مستمره والقصف المتبادل ما بين الجيشين
الروسي والاوكراني لا يتوقف الكهرباء
مقطوعه بالكامل شبكات الاتصال كلها مقطوعه
لا بد من
توثيق هذه الكارثه التي تتزامن مع
العمليات العسكريه التي لا تتوقف وهنا
لابد من الاشاره الى ان قناتي العربيه
والحدث سجلت اول دخول للصحافه العربيه في
منطقه خوفكا ووقت هذه المشاهد لقناتي
العربيه والحدث رائد الاغبر نوفيكا
قال النائب الرئيس الوزراء الروسي امارات
ان جميع خزانات المياه بشبه جزيره القرم
ممتلئه بالمياه واكد ان احتياطات المياه
في الخزانات كافيه لمده 500 يوم مضيفا ان
الوضع حول محطه كخوفك الكهرومائيه لن يؤثر
على امدادات مياه الشرب مرجعا السبب لان
شبه الجزيره يتم تزويدها بشكل مستقل
بالمياه
شبه جزيره القرمسون ارتبط بازمه شحو
المياه ازمه بدات في العام 2014 حيث بنت
اوكرانيا سدا يمنع مياه نهر دينيبرو من
الوصول الى شبه الجزيره بعد ضم روسيا لها
وقطعت المياه العذبه عن شبه جزيره القرم
عبر قناه شماليه القرم بناء السد في العام
2014 سبب عجزا يقدر بخمسه وثمانين في
المئه من حاجه القرن من المياه العذبه قطع
اوكرانيا امدادات المياه عن شبه جزيره
القرم اشعل ازمه بين الجانبين امتدت
لسنوات حيث عانى نحو مليونين ومئتي الف
نسمه في شبه جزيره القرم من شح مياه الشرب
والري في فبراير من عام 2022 روسيا تعلن
تدميرها سدا على نهر يمنع وصول المياه الى
شبه جزيره القرم فبراير من عام 2022 اعلن
رئيس القرمه الموالي لروسيا سيرجي اكسيون
اوف عوده تدفق سهل شبه الجزيره
[موسيقى]
سنه واحده بعد استقالته من الحكومه اعلن
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني الاسبق بولس
جونسون استقالته من البرلمان على خلفيه
التحقيق البرلماني حول فضيحه بارتيجايد
حيث توجه اتهامات لجونسون باستضافه
مناسبات في مقره في مقر داندا خلال جائحه
كورونا وما صاحب ذلك من انتهاك للقيود
الصحيه
خارج مكتب رئاسه الوزراء لكنه داخل قلب
العواصف بولس جونسون يغادر البرلمان
البريطاني رئيس الوزراء الاسبق يتخذ
القرار على خلفيه التحقيق البرلماني حول
فضيحه بارتيجات التي لا تزال تحاصر جونسون
رغم نهايه الجائحه فبورص تلاحقه اتهامات
خرق القيود الصحيه باستضافه مقر التينكس
حفلات في عز ازمه جائحه كورونا البالغ من
العمر 58 عاما اكد ان قراره يدخل حيز
التنفيذ فورا ما يعني بالضروره اجراء
انتخابات فرعيه ستشكل عبئا وضغطا سياسيين
مضاعفين على رئيس الوزراء الحالي
التحقيق يسعى لتحديد ما اذا كان جونسون قد
ضلل البرلمان في قضيه بارتيجات اجراء
تقوده لجنه الامتيازات البرلمانيه التي
باتت قريبه من انهاء عملها اذ قدمت
استنتاجاتها الى الزعيم السابق حسب
الصحافه البريطانيه جونسون لجنه بما سماه
تحيزا فاضحا انا حزين جدا لمغادره
البرلمان على الاقل في الوقت الحالي لكن
قبل كل شيء الشعور بالاستياء لانني اجبرت
على المغادره بطريقه غير ديمقراطيه بيان
جونسون اتهم اللجنه ايضا باصدار تقرير لم
ينشر بعد يتضمن مغالطات وتحيزا
التطورات تاتي بعد عام على اقصائهم من
تندونس بايادي غالبيه حزبه المحافظين اثر
ثلاث سنوات عجاف في السلطه تزامنت مع فتره
الجائحه وما صاحب ذلك من سلسله فضائح
اطاحت براسه في النهايه من الحكومه
والبرلمان بلال البجدين العربيه
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الايطاليه ان قراصنه
يرجح ان يكونوا مهاجرين حاولوا خطف سفينه
تركيه قباله سواحل نابولي كانت في طريقها
الى فرنسا قال وزير والدفاع الايطالي غيدو
ان القوات الايطاليه تمكنت من تحرير
السفينه التركيه التي تعرضت لهجوم
المسلحين تمكنوا من ركوب السفينه خلسه
واستخدموا اسلحه مثل الخناجر لتهديد طقمها
تجمع عشرات الالاف من المتظاهرين في شوارع
العاصمه الصربيه بلغراد للاحتجاج ضد
الحكومه وذلك بعد حادثه اطلاق نار اودت
بحياه 18 شخصا حيث طالب المحتجون
باستقالات كبار المسؤولين الحكوميين في
البلاد
[موسيقى]
الهدنه في السودان تدخل حيزه تنفيذ لاربعه
وعشرين ساعه واشنطن تؤكد مواصلتها الضغط
على الجيش والدعم لوقت الحرب
بعد اتهامه في قضيه حيازه وثائق سريه موقع
اكسيوس يؤكد ان الاتهام والادانه لا
يمنعان التراب من الترشح للرئاسه
الامريكيه 2024
كاميرا العربيه توثق حجم كارثه سدنوبك
المدمر من الجانب الروسي وترصد العالقين
وتسلط الضوء على جهود الانقاذ
في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات